in the parking lot
[Music]
hey how you doing man hey come here real
quick
hey hey hey
[Music]
excuse me
get away from the truck excuse me excuse
me excuse me
I don't want any problems are you gonna
come off I don't want any problems give
me give me some space can you do that
for me can you go sit on the table I
don't want any problems go sit on the
tail game
what is going on I was not told what was
going on at all if you don't get on
what's going on
what am I doing on the ground
what do you want I don't even know
what's going on
somebody help me we don't know what's
going on with you either but you
obviously need some help
what's your name
hey what's your name James Rose James
did you take any kind of drugs or
something no
yeah I'm good
got a camera
right there
James do you know where you're at
no I don't know
my name is David James I know you got a
little cut again
on your side I don't understand what the
problem is hey man you're fighting I'm
not fighting me okay
we've got a cap right here I never did
anything
foreign